et on vient de le dire donc malgré les
tensions le dialogue va se poursuivre
afin de parvenir à une sortie de crise
demain donc le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères va s'entretenir par
téléphone avec le secrétaire d'état
américain les précisions avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine cléroux
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe
l'a confirmé en début d'après-midi une
conversation téléphonique qui est en
effet prévue ce mardi entre le
secrétaire d'état américain et le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
à noter également que le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson
devrait s'entretenir avec vladimir
poutine dans la soirée avant de se
rendre en ukraine ce mardi le dialogue
diplomatique continue donc en dépit de
l' escalade rhétorique et de la
surenchère constaté dans les médias par
le kremlin
vous savez à notre grand regret les
médias américains ont publié ces
derniers mois une très grande quantité
d'informations non vérifiées
déformés et délibérément fausses et
provocatrice sur ce qui se passe en
ukraine et autour d'elle
cela devient déjà évident pour presque
tout le monde par conséquent il faut
avoir une attitude appropriées envers
ses publications
le fait que l'hystérie déclenchée par
washington mène réellement à l'hystérie
en ukraine où les gens préparent déjà
leur sac pour partir à la guerre est
évident ça se passe vraiment
c'est le mauvais côté très pernicieux et
nocifs de la campagne que mène
actuellement washington
depuis la dernière rencontre entre
sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken à
genève le 21 janvier dernier washington
envoyé une réponse écrite aux demandes
de moscou concernant ces garanties de
sécurité le chef de la diplomatie russe
a fait savoir que ce texte pourrait
servir de base à de futures négocier
sion mais uniquement sur des thématiques
secondaire en effet le plus important
aux yeux du kremlin c'est l'arrêt de
l'extension de l'otan vers ses
frontières une proposition qui a reçu
une fin de non recevoir
les deux hommes vont donc de nouveau
discuter négocier sur ce sujet bien que
leurs positions respectives paraissent
inconciliables